[Música]
Hoy renuevo una vida de servicio estas
fueron las primeras palabras de Carlos
III como nuevo monarca del pueblo
británico de soberano se dirigió a la
nación en una locución en la que dijo
sentir un profundo dolor por la muerte
de su madre y reconoció que su vida va a
cambiar
Carlos III llega al Trono en un momento
en el que el Reino Unido pasa por una
importante crisis inflacionaria y con
una primera ministra que apenas completa
tres días en el cargo Cuáles son los
desafíos que esperan al nuevo soberano
del Trono británico
aumenta la tensión en Brasil a poco más
de tres semanas de la primera vuelta
presidencial un seguidor del mandatario
Yair evolucionaron mató con una chao en
defensor del candidato Luis Ignacio de
Silva tenemos informes desde Brasil
nueva emisión informativa en la pantalla
de France 24 Gracias por continuar con
nosotros Mi nombre es Juan pupiales
Carlos III se dirigió a la nación como
el nuevo rey de Inglaterra fue una
locución difundida por televisión para
culminar su primera jornada al completo
como soberano del Trono real el Rey
Carlos dijo sentir un profundo dolor por
la muerte de su madre Isabel II
[Música]
con sentimientos de profunda tristeza
toda su vida Su Majestad la reina mi
amada madre fue una inspiración fue un
ejemplo para mí y para toda mi familia
le debemos a ella
tenemos cabeza una deuda muy grande la
deuda que toda familia tiene con su
madre por el afecto la guía a la
comprensión y el ejemplo que nos dio a
todos la reina la Reina Isabel era una
vida una promesa del destino
y La amamos profundamente ella cumplió
con su promesa de servicio de toda la
vida y yo hago la misma promesa hoy
con el dolor que tengo personalmente y
toda mi familia ese dolor lo comparto
con tantos de ustedes en el Reino Unido
y en todos los países donde ella fue
jefe de estado en toda la comunión Y a
lo largo de todo el mundo
un profundo sentimiento es
agradecimiento por los más de 70 años en
que mi madre fue reina de tantas
naciones
mi vida va a cambiar así lo reconoció el
propio Rey nunca antes un príncipe
heredero había esperado tanto para
ascender al Trono para muchos carros
lleva toda la vida preparándose para ese
momento escuchamos que dijo
mi vida por supuesto va a cambiar
cuando asuma esta nueva responsabilidad
ya no será posible para mí dedicarle
tanto tiempo ni tanta energía a las
obras caritativas a las que me he
dedicado con tanta devoción pero sé que
este que este trabajo tan importante va
a quedar en manos de otros
es un tiempo de cambio también para mi
familia en cuanto
con la ayuda amorosa de mi amada esposa
Camila
parece
de su compromiso con el servicio público
desde que ellas
contrajemos matrimonio ahora ella es la
reina consorte y esto exige de ella un
nuevo papel y una devoción a los deberes
y confío
William como mi heredero ahora ASUME los
títulos escoceses que significaron tanto
para mí
me sucede
y Toma las responsabilidades
que he dicho tuve durante más de cinco
décadas
hoy en día
tengo el orgullo de coronarlo como
príncipe de gales Carlos III llega al
Trono en un momento muy distinto al que
lo hizo su madre el Reino Unido
atraviesa por un momento álgido en la
política en medio de una crisis
inflacionaria con una nueva primera
ministra y además con un contexto nuevo
sobre el papel de las monarquías en el
mundo A qué retos se enfrenta Carlos
como rey
es El Monarca de mayor edad en ocupar el
trono a sus 73 años Carlos ha esperado
mucho tiempo para ser rey ahora que por
fin ha llegado el día son muchos los
retos a los que se enfrenta el décimo
tercer monarca la popularidad de su
difunta madre es uno de ellos la Reina
Isabel segunda una figura querida y
unificadora unió a menudo al país
durante sus siete décadas de reinado
Carlos nunca ha atraído el mismo amor
que su predecesora el nuevo rey se ha
enfrentado a una serie de escándalos a
lo largo de los años su divorcio de
Diana y posterior matrimonio con Camila
la salida de su hijo Harry de la familia
real entre otras cosas han empañado su
reputación lo mismo ocurre en el
extranjero donde la reina Es una figura
muy querida entre los 56 estados
miembros de la commonwealth y para
muchos ahora que la reina ha muerto Hay
pocas razones para permanecer en ella
es como dije el fin de una era en esta
nueva era Será interesante ver si es tan
popular como el pasado o si eso
significa que el apoyo puede morir un
poco o tal vez la monarquía va a cambiar
en ciertas formas
mi vida
ella ha hecho un tremendo trabajo y no
creo que Carlos pueda llevarnos a
ninguna parte y creo que es su fin
Carlos sube al Trono en un momento de
extrema incertidumbre en el país las
facturas de la energía siguen disparadas
y la inflación ha alcanzado su punto más
alto en 40 años la monarquía se enfrenta
desde hace tiempo a críticas por la
absorción de fondos públicos y con el
país al borde de la recesión un funeral
que costará millones de libras de los
contribuyentes no pasará desapercibido
con un corto comunicado del gobierno
argentino se refirió al fallecimiento de
la Reina Isabel segunda un mensaje que
contrasta con el de múltiples naciones
del continente americano con un carácter
más cercano Y es que Buenos Aires y
Londres mantienen una extensa de
relaciones desde la guerra de las Islas
malvinas informe de Manuela Cano
la muerte de la reina Isabel segunda
volcó algunas miradas a más de 12.000
kilómetros de Londres Allí se encuentran
las Islas malvinas un archipiélago que
carecía de población autóctona y cuyos
primeros ocupantes fueron europeos tras
la conquista y que ha sido el principal
punto de fricción en las relaciones
entre Argentina y Reino Unido el momento
más tenso llegó en 1982 cuando se desató
el conflicto entre los dos países para
disputar la soberanía de las Islas uno
en el que murieron más de 600 argentinos
y 255 británicos y a pesar de la
búsqueda Isabel segunda de mantener
cierta distancia con los temas políticos
la reina tuvo audiencias públicas con
margaret thatcher entonces primera
ministra de Reino Unido y quien lideró
la ofensiva de sus fuerzas armadas en
las Islas
además su hijo el príncipe Andrew peleó
en la guerra de las malvinas
tres décadas después llegó una de las
declaraciones más polémicas de la
monarca al hacer referencia a las Islas
falkland como se reconoce al
archipiélago en Reino Unido
mi gobierno garantizará la seguridad del
buen gobierno y el desarrollo de los
territorios de ultramar incluso mediante
la protección del derecho de los
habitantes de las Islas falkland y de
los gibraltareños a determinar Su futuro
político
la locución se dio en un momento crítico
pocos meses después se celebró un
referendo en el que los habitantes de
las malvinas decidieron si querían
seguir bajo la administración británica
dicha opción se impuso con más de 92% de
los votos pero el plebiscito fue
cuestionado por Argentina asegurando que
fue organizado por británicos para
británicos y no fue reconocido por
Naciones Unidas el asunto de las
malvinas también hizo presencia en la
celebración de los 70 años de la Reina
Isabel II en el trono cuando la corona
británica le dio a Puerto argentino o
Stanley la capital de las malvinas el
rango de Ciudad un estatus condenado por
Argentina
el anuncio de la corona británica sobre
Puerto argentino expone el carácter
colonial de La ilegal e ilegítima
ocupación sobre nuestras Islas malvinas
para hacer claro el territorio fue
usurpado a la Argentina hace 189 años
por una invasión militar el gobierno de
las Islas malvinas se pronunció tras el
fallecimiento de la reina destacando el
servicio de la monarca para su país y su
gente un comunicado que contrasta con la
percepción de buena parte de la sociedad
Argentina que considera las malvinas
como parte de su territorio me hubiera
gustado que la reina antes de
fallecernos no nos devolviera Como hizo
con Hong Kong no que también era una
colonia británica y las Inglaterra la la
liberado de alguna manera no
tras un escueto comunicado del gobierno
argentino la gran incógnita es como
manejará el Rey Carlos III la relación
con las malvinas
y siguiendo con las reacciones en el
mundo al fallecimiento de la Reina
Isabel segunda vamos a escuchar ahora
Fabián piccardo ministro principal de
Gibraltar Gibraltar el enclave británico
en la Península ibérica
todo el conjunto de la sociedad
gibraltadeña ha sentido un ondísimo
pesado cuando hemos recibido la noticia
de la muerte de Isabel II
Gibraltar queda su Roca pero ella
también era nuestras rocas en momentos
difíciles y edad sobre ella que habíamos
creado la democracia moderna que soy
Gibraltar en estos momentos de Gran
tristeza hemos agradecido muchísimo los
mensajes que nos llegan desde España en
particular desde el campo de Gibraltar
donde alcalde y amigos de Gibraltar nos
traspasan sus pésames por nuestro
momento tan difícil Y de esa manera nos
ayudan en estos momentos de Gran
tristeza cambiamos de tema los ministros
de energía de la Unión Europea acordaron
este viernes en reducir el consumo de
Electricidad esto en medio de la escasez
de reservas de gas por las que
atraviesan varios países del bloque
producto de la guerra en Ucrania y el
suministro limitado que está llegando
desde Rusia desde Bruselas nuestra
corresponsal Esther Herrera nos entregó
el siguiente in
los ministros de energía de la Unión
Europea han pedido que se intervenga de
urgencia el mercado eléctrico de la
Unión Europea ante la escalada de
precios que están sufriendo Todos los
países hay que recordar que ahora mismo
el gas está a máximos históricos y que
es precisamente el gas el que dictamina
el precio de la electricidad por ello
los ministros de energía han pedido que
se ponga un límite al gas aunque no solo
el ruso sino a todo tipo de gas Aunque
es una medida que no genera todo el
consenso y habrá que ver si sale
adelante por otra parte sí que genera
más consenso que los beneficios que han
conseguido las empresas eléctricas
durante esta crisis de precios vayan a
parar a los consumidores y también a las
empresas que más lo necesitan para pagar
sus facturas por otra parte también a
los países han apoyado que se reduzca el
consumo de electricidad en horas punta y
así poder reducir esta electricidad
Aunque habrá que verse habrá un
porcentaje obligatorio ahora la comisión
europea tendrá que hacer una propuesta
legislativa la semana que viene con el
objetivo de que los países lo pueden
aprobar todo antes de finalizar el mes
ya hay fecha para la reaperturar
completo de las fronteras terrestres
entre Venezuela y Colombia así como la
reanudación de los vuelos directos entre
ambos países suspendidos desde 2019 será
el próximo 26 de septiembre las
relaciones entre Caracas y Bogotá dieron
un giro de 180 grados desde la llegada
al poder en Colombia del presidente
Gustavo Petro esto el 7 de agosto según
Petro estos pasos anunciados este
viernes confirman el compromiso para
restablecer relaciones de humanidad
mientras que es homólogo venezolano
Nicolás Maduro detalló que se van a
retomar las rutas entre Caracas y Bogotá
y Valencia y Bogotá desde el pasado 29
de agosto Colombia y Venezuela empezaron
a normalizar sus relaciones con el
regreso de sus respectivos Embajadores
lo avanzamos en titulares a poco más de
tres semanas de la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en Brasil
aumenta la tensión la policía dio a
conocer este viernes y un seguidor del
mandatario Yahir evolucionaron mató con
un hacha y apuñaladas a un defensor del
expresidente y candidato Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva Esto ocurrió en el estado
de mato grosso y es el segundo ataque
violento de este tipo desde julio desde
Río de Janeiro nuestra corresponsal en
Brasil Valeria sakone nos entregó
previamente más detalles
nuevo acto de violencia política en
Brasil durante la campaña electoral hoy
una defensor del presidente Chávez
bolsonaro de 22 años ha sido arrestado
por haber matado a un apoyador del ex
presidente Lula aconteció el 7 de
septiembre el día de la independencia de
Brasil en mato grosso un estado del
interior de Brasil los dos discutieron
trabajaban juntos cortando leña y Rafael
Silva de 22 años mató a su víctima
usando un hacha y un puñal no es la
primera vez que acontece un bolsonarista
en julio mató al tesorero del partido de
los trabajadores en foz de iguazú en el
sur del país al río de aquí en bolsonaro
ambos eran policías y la víctima estaba
celebrando su cumpleaños en una fiesta
caracterizadas con fotos de Lula y hoy
aquí en San Gonzalo en la periferia de
Río de Janeiro ha habido un acto de
evangélicos a favor de la izquierda en
el que el propio Lula ha comparecido un
ex candidato municipal aparecido con un
coche con fotos de Lula entre rejas ha
habido una discusión y finalmente un
militante de izquierdas ha agredido al
provocador la cosa no he ido a más pero
se teme que la violencia electoral vaya
escalando a medida de que se acerca la
fecha del 2 de octubre
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
quédense en la pantalla de France 24
[Música]